The groundwork of innovation and achievement
is ideas.
The ability to imagine something that does
not yet exist.
To create synergy between our thoughts and
the world.
Unfortunately though, our ideas are not always
good.
In general, it is more likely that the majority
of our ideas are bad.
But if hypothetically, let’s say one in
ten ideas are good, than the goal is to come
up with as many ideas as possible.
All it takes is one good idea, coupled with
proper execution, to ignite an explosion of
innovation and achievement.
In order to capture and execute the rare good
ideas swimming around inside your head, you
must go through a process of idea collection.
This involves collecting every idea that floats
to the surface of your consciousness.
There is a sea of thought flowing beneath
your conscious perception filled with the
potential for powerful life-changing ideas.
Ideas float to the surface when they are facilitated
and inspired by new experiences, new understandings,
and new perspectives.
To capitalize on this, you must grab every
idea that surfaces and bring it into shore.
By simply writing your ideas down, you capture
them.
But if not written down promptly after consciously
perceiving them, they will sink back into
the subconscious and there is no guarantee
that they will re-surface.
Once you begin to gather your ideas on the
shoreline, the next and very important step
is evaluation.
After letting your ideas dry off for a bit,
you must evaluate the validity and potential
of them.
You should trust in the potential of your
ideas but also thoroughly examine them with
objectivity and reason.
If your ideas make it past this process, go
one further and test them out with carefully
selected friends, family members, and colleagues.
Observe their reactions and open yourself
up to their feedback.
Work to subtract your pride and ego from the
equation in order to absorb their feedback
fully and without resistance.
Any stake of vanity that you hold within your
idea prevents clear and rational consideration
of its true potential.
Once you have genuinely considered both your
own and other people’s evaluations and you
know in your heart of hearts that you have
synthesized an idea of great value, you will
become synchronized with its energy.
You will struggle to think of anything other
than the pursuit of its realization.
At which point, you must execute the idea.
You must work to bring it into reality using
any infrastructure you have or can assemble.
Once you have made this decision to pursue
an idea into fruition, you must follow it
through without waver, for the greatest demise
of a good idea is indecision and uncertainty.
Employ the power of definitive effort towards
a good idea, and allow it to take its course.
If the idea is in fact a good one, it will
in time bring great abundance
to that which it is designed to serve.